what's up everyone I thought I would
give you a little behind the scenes of
what it looks like when I'm making my
audiobook so i'm here at the Cherry
beach studio downtown Toronto it's the
home of Justin Bieber and Ludacris and
Rihanna and 50 cent and all these big
recording artists when they're in town
and I'm on my lunch break recording my
audio book lunch is this broccoli bread
soup in some chicken fingers and veggies
that I need to get through and I want to
take you on a little tour what I'm what
I'm doing here this is where my producer
sits has all his gear there and I have
another producer who joins from skype
who coaches me on what I need to do
better and take you behind the scenes
here this is where I'm doing all the
magic we actually had a chair here but I
took it out because I prefer standing up
I get energy and vibe when I'm standing
up as opposed to sitting down this is
what I'm looking at so we got a
microphone with a with a windscreen
there and then my notes are here someone
page we're making really good progress
I'm on page what 164 we're halfway
through a good day you supposed to get
through 80 pages last Monday my first
day I did 120 and we're through 44 now
and then i will keep doing some more
later on today so pretty pumped about
that we keep this this thing here so
when I'm speaking it bounces the sound
off of and then I'm usually I get these
headphones on where the guy in skype is
kind of giving me direction I got my
coffee can take notes and it's good it's
so it's it's really demanding its taxing
I always lose my voice at the end of
these but it's so much fun is so much
fun like channeling you guys knowing
that this is what is going to be you
guys really listen to in the car on the
subway whatever it is I'm channeling
that into me and I wanted to give you a
little behind-the-scenes
behind-the-scenes of what it takes to
make a hit a future hit audio book
there's a I'm wearing I'm wearing shorts
can you see the shorts
shorts they're actually paints that rip
off because it gets hot in here it gets
hot in here it's this tiny room their
main stages in there when Bieber and
those guys can with a band they do it in
here but if it's a solo person to do it
in here because the sound is easier for
one person but it gets hot in here it
gets super hot in here there's one vent
on the wall let me show you up there
that's the one vent coming in but it
gets hot because they don't they don't
want any fan sounds they don't want he
were happening on the background it
sounds so crisp it's so much better than
the sound that I put on the other stuff
even the lav mic or my Yeti might gets a
lot better so the first day I was lucky
that I wore pants that were you could
rip off because it does get it's nice
and hot in here so we get this door
little bit open so that i get a breeze
but also the energy the energy that
we're firing out generate some nice heat
to so just finishing off the lunch and
then going to get back we still have we
still have this much this much to read
that's it for the sneak peak guys I'll
see you soon all right I'm all done walk
out of the studio we got the whole thing
done we took an extra half an hour just
to wrap up we're like done on time and
you're like hey we got 10 more pages can
we get it done they'll probably take
about half an hour 20 minutes so I don't
have to come back next week we got the
associated three days to do it I did it
in two and man guys that is fire at the
end I'm like I'm so into it and so like
wrapping everything up I'm just yelling
into the microphone and then if I miss a
word or something to like okay you got
to redo that product oh you're killing
my vibe I was feeling it I was on a roll
anyway it's been such an awesome process
just realizing how much love is in the
book and how if you guys apply even a
quarter a tenth of what's in there it's
going to have such a dramatic change on
you and your business I'm so excited to
see this thing come out
you know I wrote it I'd forget how long
ago right and everything was like chunks
at a time and now seen it all together
man I'm fired up I'm so fired up you
guys are gonna love it so those you guys
who got the e-book you're gonna love it
you got the regular booking love it too
but then the amount of bar coming into
the e-book I'm so juiced up anyway I
gotta I gotta quickly rush home because
I'm now I'm late I've saved the chicken
fingers free mean that cuz she said if I
have chicken fingers I had to bring her
home some so that's it I get next monday
off hopefully less there's some
technical issue that they need to deal
with the editor looks at it and then
they call what are they called pickups
pickups like I made a mistake or said
something wrong reading it was a
technical issue and apparently after the
first day there was nothing wrong they
loved everything which is awesome there
was nothing to pick up or they didn't
that or they then listen to it but it's
usually super rare to have no pickups
and so hopefully today with no pickups
to and which is done I have can't wait
to listen to it guys I'm so excited
anyway okay I'm late I gotta go I gotta
go much love continue to believe I
believe in you guys or whatever you're
wondering where it is and I'll see you
soon goodbye